was a big day for joe biden don't take
my word for it just listen to the always
honest and ever forthcoming uh white
house propagandist jen saki circling
back
so the president has nothing on his
schedule today aside from the pdb can
you shed any light on how he's spending
his day
well let's see um this morning i think
he had some policy meetings also a pdb
meeting
he
later this afternoon i think is doing
some
remarks review there are some days that
we spend some time doing internal
meetings and discussions with policy
experts with policy leaders
and that's that's what's happening today
he would say he doesn't have nearly
enough time or free time on his schedule
because it is packed no matter whether
people see him or not
that's right zero official events on the
schedule the average is less than one a
day anyway zero today
but that doesn't mean joe was doing
nothing take a look at your screen here
he is out and about in beautiful
washington dc at a woman's clothing uh
boutique doing a little shopping joe
even picked out a brand new mug with
kamala harris's face on the front see
how wonderful it is they really don't
hate each other at all like the press
has been suggesting even though it's
clear their relationship is extremely
tense now of course he also took some
time to gaze at women's blouses very
important work for a president and when
you look at this here he is enjoying
some much-needed ice cream and joey even
got his favorite flavor chocolate what
inflation what covert what border crisis
what russia ukraine crisis uh no doubt
for a guy who doesn't often leave the
house it was a really really big day
he's probably sleeping by now filled
with fun and adventure and yet somehow
joe still managed to find time to answer
this important question take a look can
you tell me whether you think sir that
the risk of an invasion is increasing or
decreasing or steady just as as it has
been these recent days
you know
i'll be completely honest with you it's
a little bit like reading tea leaves
there you have it the biden doctrine
reading the tea leaves just like he read
the tea leaves in afghanistan
you remember what joe proclaimed we had
all the leverage over the taliban and
he'd never abandoned any americans by
the way it's been 164 days americans
held hostage abandoned behind enemy
lines day 164
in joe biden's world of sunshine cotton
candy lollipops rainbows chocolate ice
cream there's nothing to worry about not
afghanistan not a 40-year high of
inflation no supply chain crisis no
worker shortage no border crisis no
covet crisis you know think about it
there are now ongoing catastrophes at
home and abroad europe is on the cusp of
war joe biden is in a clothing boutique
looking at a lady's blouse anyway with
no other events on his schedule none
tonight i have a message whoever's
really running the show at the white
house we the american people are not
stupid now it is now painfully obvious
to everyone joe is not fit to serve u.s
presidents don't just hang out at ice
cream parlors and then call it a day at
three o'clock in the afternoon that is
not normal and of course by all accounts
joe has never been well to be blunt the
sharpest tool in the shed anyway
remember he plagiarized speeches cheated
in law school still finished near the
bottom of his class lied about that too
high-level officials in the obama
administration they even openly mocked
joe for getting pretty much everything
wrong but now it's serious and much
worse as a reminder here is joe biden
throughout the years take a look
in our bilateral relationships with
nations with whom we deal and have
serious trade deficits we have to be
willing to put more cards on the table
and in that neighborhood there was
filled with women and men mothers and
fathers who taught their children if
they believed in themselves if they were
honest if they worked hard if they loved
their country they could accomplish
anything we believed it and we did now
they got a new plan trust me it's not
going to cost you any more folks follow
your instincts on this one they put one
foot in front of the other
they keep going
that's the unbreakable spirit of the
people of america
i would say that was a pretty
cognitively aware sharp combative joe
biden now let's take a moment and
compare what you just heard to biden's
recent press conference from just last
week see if you notice a discernible
difference you decide take a look
the idea that um
the um
[Music]
but the nature
not
when
the political coverage
[Music]
that
look
um
some of the political
players
and some of the
[Music]
let me ask a rhetorical question
[Music]
no anyway
ask yourself how does that make you feel
for me i'm embarrassed and humility i
find it humiliating for our country
here's an obvious question that no one
in the media mob will dare ask does joe
biden
have the mental strength and capacity
to serve as the president of the united
states now we're going to ask two
doctors his very question now i'm not a
medical professional but it appears to
me to be very transparent very obvious
very clear and so many others that joe
biden is in a steep cognitive decline it
seems to be accelerating to me we know
that he required not one but two
potentially degenerative brain surgeries
from aneurysms during his time in the
u.s senate and we can all see that biden
now struggles to find words these long
awkward
pauses of his often confusing names and
places and dates he has these you know
bouts of sudden anger are very real over
the past few days joe called not one but
two fox news reporters stupid even one a
son of a [ __ ] even accused another
reporter of not knowing how to read
today jen saki did her very best to try
and clean up that mess without
apologizing of course why would they say
they're sorry not that i care but take a
look
forgive me it's sort of the elephant the
room um
many people in the country were talking
about it last night this morning
does the president regret saying what he
said about peter can you shed some light
if you have any comfort have had any
conversations with him today about what
happened last night
well i i would say what's most important
and i it's peter's sitting here so this
is kind of a funny thing but uh the pro
the president uh the president um called
peter and i he confirmed this so this is
only why i'm speaking to this and if you
have private conversations with the
president i will assure you i'm not
going to convey that on your behalf but
peter spoke to this the president called
him he conveyed
to him that it was nothing personal man
and also acknowledged that all of you
are going to ask him a range of
questions so i think that speaks for
itself
no hard feelings pal by the way unlike
fake news cnn and every liberal in the
country you know we're not gonna fake
and feign and moral outrage i don't
really give a rip what what joe biden
says to anybody it's not personal fine
i'll take it that way joe is apparently
unable to control his bursts of anger
and so many other cognitive troubles all
right so last night we did this on the
program and our friend geraldo rivera
does not believe joe biden is mentally
unfit he doesn't think that the
president is in a steep cognitive
decline before we get to geraldo i want
to play a clip unlike joe biden geraldo
sorry to do this to you over the years
we went back and we did the same thing
with you you have not changed at all
take a look
right this is the big bagram air base
our main base in afghanistan and this is
the falcon defect defect that's dining
facility to those of you who don't speak
military jargon he's a political pundit
a martial arts champion of course a
best-selling author most recently of
black belt patriotism had a reawaken
america he is chuck norris it was the
trial of the 20th century the longest in
the history of california 10 months 150
witnesses called to the courthouse here
in downtown los angeles this is where
they are seeing an enormous influx of
migrant families coming without
documentation major dangerous stoners
there hi everybody i'm harald rivera
welcome to copswell access the revival
season is rolling out exclusively right
here on fox nation
exact same guy 20 years later so i have
another question after seeing this does
our friend and he is our friend gerald
rivera now believe joe biden has lost
more than just a step and with so much
at stake it's the most important job
hardest job in the world don't the
american people deserve to see the
results of a cognitive test like donald
trump took so that we can know that this
president is okay hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else